kojimi was a pro-democracy activist
jose tour a former hip-hop artist and
member of parliament
but the myanmar military said they were
terrorists and hanged them along with
two other activists
these were the first executions in the
country in more than 30 years carried
out despite pleas from the international
community not to go ahead
it's even over a year now since the
military attempted to stage a coup and
they haven't been
able to consolidate power and this
execution is a sign of desperation for
the military that they will do anything
they can and they want to create fear in
people so people will stop standing up
against the
military the military seized power in
february last year after aung sang
pro-democracy party won a landslide
election
it has struggled to control the protests
that have erupted since then despite
shooting unarmed protesters
rights groups say there have been more
than 2 000 extrajudicial killings and
under the military disputes
but it's also used the judiciary to try
and crush the opposition
aung suchi herself has already been
sentenced to 11 years in prison but
faces further charges that together
carry a maximum sentence of more than
180 years this is a real wake-up call
for the international community that
they cannot allow myanmar to just slide
off the table uh you know to be
concerned too much about other things
and and ignore myanmar's uh worsening
civil war and the human rights
atrocities that are going along with it
uh this is a call for attention now uh
for the international community to step
back in and recognize that asean doesn't
have the wherewithal to solve this
problem
the united nations and the asean group
of southeast asian countries had begged
the military not to go ahead with the
executions
they paid those in treaties no heed
nor will they care about the
condemnation unless there is firmer
action
tom cheshire sky news beijing